Các bạn một tôn này các cơ sử dụng trụ thằng chục tấn bánh kèc
đô ăn hết hạn chắn ra đường đồng tiến
xá là phụ thịt hoài đức
anh rộng đến nhiều hộ ra đường xong xong quanh
Cậu thân hôm qua
mình đi ra là người đi
đẹp thứ liệu
anh ấy có hã khổ
có hòa về
đường rất cứ của đồng rộng
dồi nhận của người này
có bây đây nhạm hồi thôi
nhà anh tới tốt cắt nhỏ
thủ quán bây giờ
nhiều khí khoảng
tạng là hiểm khuốc hàng thân cMúsica
mình chưa gọi thì nhỏ sẽ khủy tập mình sông
nhưng...
nó có chú cạnh làm
nó chände và cho giới rồi
cho mình còn này
cái kh Bak Chó Tí chuyện vàng bồi
đưa đi rộng át thải
mình cũng mới l kil tất thải
mạnh kèc
rộng át th 可以
khiுr gọi
chừng các lời
đá tập két tôi đâu
thì giết là...
vẫn ảnh trả rồi ra rồi
chúng ta có mắt sạm
và tiếp tục kiểm tra sắc mới.
Chúng ta đã đoạn ngà mà có thể chích xuất được ca mê ra amy,
chỉ là hát hiện.
Các cái trường hợp mà nó có...
mang...
chất thái.
Gòn chúc.
Rà đồ tại.
Phu vai ra không đúng cuối được khắp lột.
Lấy sự li theo đình pháp bật, mấy chua.
Tự đời đồ của đi phí trường,
không anh thường chức pháp tầm chi lưu,
lưng sao làm việc của yếu anh sao?
Đà phát, mất sắc mới chỉ lộng chung rồi.
Lên quan thì tại hiện chung đã có đều hình gặp,
Vậy quan nhát mắt, đừng bị nào để xác phát hiện ra, chỉ để bán.
Đừng đừng nào để con tiết, phải sắc mình tiếp.